[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about all seven members
of the seven deadly sins including their
background and origins their powers and
abilities and more here on the channel
we made multiple news videos about the
seven that descends season-two back in
2017 and all of those videos received a
ton of support and many of you requested
more 7 Deadly Sins content on this
channel I know that not too fired up in
particular requested at a bunch of times
along with many others and for that
reason we decided to make this video
explaining everything you need to know
about all seven members of the seven
deadly sins in one place
this video will contain spoilers about
the backstory and the unique abilities
of the seven deadly sins so proceed with
caution although I will do my best to
avoid spoilers about what happens later
on in the story for those of you who are
not caught up with the manga however if
you are one of those people who doesn't
want any type of spoiler ever you have
been warned I want to give a big
shout-out to Briggs from all-day anime
he has been making quality 7 Deadly Sins
content for quite a while and he will
also be uploading weekly episode reviews
for 7 Deadly Sins season 2 on his
channel feel free to check him out link
in the description if you want to see
more 7 Deadly Sins content on this
channel leave a like to let me know and
if you are new don't forget to subscribe
and click that notification bell by the
way we are now posting daily on both
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar the
first sin that we meet in the very first
episode of the anime and the first
chapter of the manga is the dragon sin
of Wrath meliodas or meliodas depending
on whether you watch the dub or the sub
although he is the notorious captain of
the seven deadly sins we first meet
meliodas as the fun-loving and carefree
owner of the bore hat tavern because he
is very small come
pair to the other adult characters and
also because he looks nothing like his
wanted posters at first many people
assumed that Mellie Otis is just some
kid and they often grossly underestimate
his true power it can seem a bit
paradoxical that Mellie Otis is the sin
of wrath
since he seems to be an incredibly
easygoing person who likes to joke
around and have fun and he is also known
to be merciful and to avoid killing
anyone whenever possible
however when someone he cares about is
in danger and he is driven over the edge
we see a black mark appear on his
forehead and Mellie Otis seems to lose
control over himself this is when his
wrath truly comes out and he quickly and
brutally destroys his opponents without
a second thought and without any
expression on his face at the end of
season one and in the OVA we learned
that the type of black markings that
appear on melioidosis forehead are
connected to the demon clan and
eventually we learned that Mellie Otis
himself is a member of the demon clan
not only is he not a kid he is over
3,000 years old and he is the oldest son
of the demon king the ruler of the demon
clan in fact the reason that meliodas
has such a calm and carefree personality
is because he needs to be this way in
order to keep his emotions under control
if he loses control of his immense
demonic power terrible things will
happen and innocent people will get hurt
this has happened in the past and as a
result Merlin another member of the
seven deadly sins had to use her magic
to seal away the majority of melioidosis
power and she did this in order to stop
him from losing control again although
he uses multiple weapons throughout the
series the first weapon that we see
meliodas use is dragon handle a broken
sword which enables him to effectively
use full counter full counter is the
ability to literally counter a magical
attack and reflected back at his
opponent with even greater power than
the original attack and the more
effective the opponent's magic the more
effective full counter is however full
counter does have its limitations for
example while it is effective against
magical attacks it cannot counter
physical attacks we later learned that
melioidosis dragon handle is one of the
keys required to open the coffin of
eternal darkness which was used to seal
away the demon clan and the previous
holy war Mele ODIs also possesses an
ability known as hel blaze that allows
him to create and manipulate mysterious
black flames this power is directly
related to the demon clan and it is
strong enough to hurt even immortal
creatures and stop them from
regenerating when he loses control and
the demonic power takes over Mele Oda's
becomes even more powerful than he is
normally but the drawback is that he
cannot contain the power and there can
be terrible collateral damage the name
of melioidosis sacred treasure is the
demon sword lost vein which is an ornate
curved sword that was given to him by
king Bartra lost vein enables meliodas
to create clones of himself he can
create up to four clones but the clones
will be significantly weaker than the
original when the seven deadly sins went
into hiding after being framed for
killings are atras meliodas sold his
sacred treasure in order to finance the
bore hat tavern but the treasure was
retrieved by merlin melioidosis favorite
pastime in life seems to be getting very
up close and very personal with
Elizabeth the second member of the seven
deadly sins that we meet is Dion or Dian
the Serpent's sin of envy she is a
member of the giant clan which is why
she is so much bigger than all the other
characters and why she often inspires
fear and people even though she is
actually a friendly and kind person
throughout her life her immense size
often made her an outcast because
regular-sized people saw her as a threat
and this made her feel very lonely to
the point that she sometimes even wishes
that she was small like everyone else as
a child she actually left a giant clan
to
on her own because the giant clan is
known for their lava fighting and Diane
didn't want to fight
and this again emphasizes her kind and
gentle nature
Diane has strong feelings towards
meliodas because he recruited her into
the seven deadly sins and treated her
with kindness
despite her massive size and the reason
that her sin is envy likely stems from
the fact that she envies those who are
of a normal size and don't have to be
outcasts like her
Diane is known for her incredible
physical strength and stamina and she is
especially effective in defense as a
giant she has a unique ability known as
creation that enables her to manipulate
the earth in order to create massive
weapons and even moving creatures such
as the golems she created to keep her
company as a child her sacred treasure
is Gideon a massive Warhammer that
enhances Diane's physical ability and
earth manipulating powers whoa I just
realized that Diane is both an
earthbender and the Warhammer Titan
[Music]
best crossover ever the next member of
the seven deadly sins that we meet in
Episode four of the anime in Chapter
seven of the manga is the fox's sin of
greed bond during the forest of white
dreams arc Gil Thunder tells meliodas
that bond has been a prisoner for five
years and he was even tortured but when
he hears that the captain of the seven
deadly sins meliodas is alive bond
simply breaks out of prison without much
trouble we learned that bond actually
let himself be imprisoned on purpose
five years earlier because he was
depressed and torture makes him feel
alive and we also see that no matter how
many times he is stabbed or injured his
body heals on its own when we first meet
bond he has a beard and long hair and
personally I thought he looked really
cool with the beard but during his
battle with Jericho at the prison he
lets her essentially groom him with her
sword until his hair is shorter and his
face is shaved quite away let me know if
you think bond looks cooler with a beard
or without a beard personally I'm
leaning towards the beard bond is an
eccentric and fun-loving guy who loves
to roughhouse with Mellie Otis but he
can also take things too far as he did
when he tried to take Mellie Otis's
dragon handle Mellie Otis refused to let
bond take the sword and instead he
slashed bond across the face this is the
only wound that bond has received which
doesn't heal on its own and he still has
a scar on his face to prove it we can
assume that Mellie Otis is so protective
of the sword because he knows that it
can be used to open the coffin of
eternal darkness and release the demon
clan later on in the series we learned
that in his youth bond was abandoned and
his goal was to find the Fountain of
Youth and to drink from it in order to
become immortal his past as a thief and
his desire for the Fountain of Youth is
probably the reason why he is the fox's
sin of greed twenty years before the
start of the series he entered the fairy
Kings forest and found the Fountain of
Youth but he was stopped from drinking
from it by Alene a fairy who was in
charge of protecting the foul
and while her brother the fairy king was
away bond and Elaine spent some time
together inside the forest and they fell
in love but their relationship was cut
short by a red demon who attacked the
forest and fatally injured both bond and
Elaine in order to save bond Elaine made
him drink water from the Fountain of
Youth
while this saved bonds life and made him
immortal Elaine died in this broke bonds
heart bond was later accused of being
the one who destroyed the forest and
killed Elaine in order to get to the
Fountain of Youth but no matter how many
times the authorities tried to execute
him he simply couldn't die as he
languished in prison devastated by the
loss of Elaine he was discovered by
Mellie Otis and eventually recruited
into the seven deadly sins while
publicly bond loves to drink joke around
and have fun in private he is haunted by
Elaine's death and his ultimate passion
and borderline obsession is to find a
way to somehow revive her apart from
being immortal meaning he doesn't age
and his body regenerates instantly from
injuries he is also very fast and strong
he has a special ability called snatch
which enables him to steal objects from
others without making direct contact
including the vital organs of his
opponents if he chooses bond can also
steal the power stamina and speed of his
opponents which makes his opponent
progressively weaker as bond becomes
stronger however bond is limited in
terms of how much power he can steal
from others before he cannot handle any
more bonds sacred treasure is known as
courage juice not sure about the
pronunciation of these names because
they come from our turian legend bond
sacred weapon is a staff divided into
four parts and connected by chains and
it actually reminds me a little bit of
nunchucks I personally think that bond
is one of the coolest characters in the
series and I love how his personality is
a mix of getting drunk and joking around
on the one hand and being desperately
heartbroken and obsessed with reviving
Elaine his true love on the other
after bond the next member of the seven
deadly sins that we meet is the grisly
sin of
sloth king also known as Harlequin the
king of the fairies as suggested by his
title king is a fairy and he is actually
the brother of Elaine he has a fairy
form in which he looks like a young boy
despite being over 1,000 years old and
he also has a human form in which he
becomes a big chubby dude with like a
sideburns beard type thing going on when
we first meet King he is working with
the holy Knights and he wants to kill
bond because he believes the false
accusations that bond destroyed the
fairy Kings forest and killed Elaine
King was once the protector of the
forest and he lived there together with
Elaine and other fairies but after his
best friend halgrim left the forest to
see the human world King went after him
and left the duty of protecting the
forest to Elaine hell broom and the
other fairies that went with him were
tricked by humans and killed for their
wings because the wings were worth a lot
of money in the human world and when
King found out what happened he was
attacked by a human called Aldrich and
nearly killed before he was rescued by a
young Dian however as a result of the
attack King lost his memories and so he
never returned to the fairy Kings forest
to continue his duty of protecting it
Kings relationship with Diane developed
and he eventually regained his memories
but he ultimately decided to erase
Diane's memories of himself so she
doesn't remember the time they spend
together King was eventually arrested
for abandoning his duties as the fairy
King and for failing to stop his best
friend hellbrunn from murdering innocent
humans for revenge and since he was
imprisoned King couldn't return to the
forest in time to save it and Elaine
from the red demon Kings sin of sloth
meaning idleness or laziness stems from
the fact that he abandoned his duties as
the fairy king and protector of the
forest in general King appears to be
rational and intelligent
however he has strong romantic feelings
for Diane even though he isn't able to
express them to her and this can lead
him to behave in a rash and jealous
manner because he is a fairy king can
fly and also transform his appear
although in terms of pure physical
strength he is quite weak King is fast
and has immense magical power as the
fairy king he has a special ability
called disaster which allows him to
control and modify organic matter
including nature Kings sacred treasure
is the spirit spear chassis offal which
was made from the sacred tree from the
fairy realm the treasure can change its
shape into everything from a pillow or a
stuffed animal to a deadly spear and
Kings ability disaster which has power
over nature allows him to bring out the
full potential of his sacred treasure
Kings primary interest in life is Dayan
and he hopes to one day marry her he
actually won the Nana to no taizai
popularity poll making him one of the
most popular characters according to
Japanese manga readers next up is the
goat sin of lust golfer
first revealed in episode 14 of the
anime and chapter 53 of the manga
because in his wanted posters Gotha is
shown only in his large armor when we
first meet a very large creature in
armor being accompanied by a thin and
calm young man who is really into books
it is natural to assume that golfer a
member of the notorious seven deadly
sins is the large armored creature
however we soon learned that the armored
creature is actually bail a human who
was turned into a demon by drinking
demon blood and who ultimately lost
control over his own mind the real
golfer is the thin young man and he gave
Dale his own enchanted armor in order to
keep Dale's demonic powers in check at
least temporarily later on in the manga
we learned that golfer is actually a
doll who was artificially created by a
demon but I won't talk about that too
much here I plan to talk more about the
demons in a separate video the fact that
golfer is a doll makes it difficult for
him to understand human emotions which
is why he often appears cold and
monotone he reads a lot of books in
order to understand humans better but it
is hard for him to grab
human emotions just by reading books
however we do know that Golder has
empathy and compassion because of the
kindness he shows Dale and others
including animals in the forest and
other people such as Jia or Julia
Elizabeth and the other members of the
seven deadly sins Goethe er is the sin
of lust because believe it or not in his
past he was accused of engaging in
lustful acts with a princess
nevertheless the accusations were false
and Gotha is not guilty of any
inappropriate lewd stuff that we know of
because he is a doll go Thurs body is
highly resistant to physical attacks and
he can take the type of damage that
would kill a normal person and still
survive even if his head is detached
from his body he can simply reattach it
both there has a very interesting and
incredibly powerful special ability
known as invasion which enables him to
read the minds of others and trap them
inside their own traumatic memories
Coulter also has the ability to
transform parts of his body like the
color and length of his hair the name of
his sacred treasure is Herod and it
allows him to summon two bows made of
pure energy that he can fire at
opponents when used together with his
ability invasion the bows allow Golder
to rewrite the memories of a large
number of people at long range due to
the fact that he is a doll golfer
doesn't need to eat or drink his glasses
by the way are not just for show without
them he actually has a very poor vision
near the end of season one of the anime
we meet the sixth member of the seven
deadly sins the boar sin of gluttony
Merlin known as the most powerful mage
in all of Britannia Merlin is actually
over 3,000 years old and her true name
cannot be pronounced by humans so she
uses Merlin for the sake of practicality
Merlin was born in Bella Lewin a city
once known as the capital of the Wizards
and her birth was a momentous occasion
because she was apparently born with
infinite magic the
waring goddess and demon clans both
tried to get Merlin to come over to
their side during the previous holy war
and they each offered secret magical
knowledge in return for her support
rather than picking either side Merlin
took the knowledge offered by both sides
angry that they've been tricked the
rulers of the goddess and demon clans
destroyed the entire city of beli a
Luwin but Merlin managed to escape the
destruction and became the only known
survivor from the capital of the wizard
her sin of gluttony is most likely
related to this Merlin had such a hunger
for magical knowledge and the secrets of
the goddess and demon clans that she
couldn't choose between the two because
she wanted at all in fact her greatest
ambition seems to be to consume all the
knowledge that there is to know in the
world as a result an entire city was
destroyed and this is the sin that
Merlin has to bear Merlin has known
meliodas for a very long time and she
was instrumental in establishing the
seven deadly sins because she was the
one who helped me Leodis identified the
other five recruits she was also the one
who gave Golder his enchanted armor as
britannia straightest mage Merlin has
immense magical powers and possesses
many magical abilities one of her
special abilities is infinity which
enables her to make her spells last
forever she even used a spell to make
her own body stop aging at age 30
making her virtually immortal and in the
world of the seven deadly sins her
magical abilities are considered to be
in an entirely different league from the
powers of an ordinary mage Merlin also
has the ability known as absolute cancel
which allows her to cancel out and erase
the spells of others she can use her
magic to locate a specific person or
object in an area the size of an entire
city the name of her sacred treasure is
the morning star of all Dan the full
magical properties of this treasure are
still unknown but we know that Merlin
can use it to look in on what's
happening in other places and to
shoot-off spells as mentioned earlier
her primary drive in life is learning
everything there is to know and in that
sense she is a glutton for knowledge and
the final member of the seven deadly
sins that we meet is the Lyon sin of
pride Eskin or although he isn't
officially introduced in the anime until
season two we do see a brief glimpse of
him in the final episode of the signs of
a holy war TV special ESCA noir is a 40
year old human and he has a very unique
power which first manifested in his
youth while at nighttime he is by far
the weakest of the seven deadly sins as
the Sun begins to rise each day a
scanners power grows immensely every
hour until it reaches its maximum height
at noon as his power grows so does his
body he becomes incredibly tall and
muscular until he reaches his peak at
noon at which point he towers over
regular people both in terms of stature
and power at noon each day a scanners
power is at its highest for one minute
and at this point
Merlin states that s Kannur is easily
the strongest of all the seven deadly
sins as he becomes an invincible
incarnation of power s canora's
personality changes along with his power
level at night he is weaker than even an
average human and he is quiet bashful
and polite during the day as his power
grows he becomes increasingly arrogant
egotistical and prideful which explains
why s Kannur is the sin of pride he
enjoys poetry as a child he was
ostracized and mistreated because of his
unique powers that other people feared
and s Kannur is in love with Merlin
because she was the first person who did
not consider him to be some sort of
monster because of his strange power the
name of esken or sacred treasure is the
divine axe Rita a massive and
excruciating ly heavy battle axe in his
daytime form s Kannur gives off an
immense amount of heat which can
actually hurt those around him but his
sacred treasure allows him
to gather and store all of that excess
energy inside the axe and then release
it later when he needs to do to the wild
fluctuations of his power between day
and night it is virtually impossible to
measure the true extent of
esken or power and that is it all seven
members of the seven deadly sins
explained I have to admit I really
enjoyed making this video and talking
about these awesome characters I
actually saw season 1 of the anime twice
and then I read the manga but all of
this was a long time ago so I really
liked getting back into it and
researching these characters again let
me know down below who your favorite
member of the seven deadly sins is for
me right now it's probably a tie between
Melly Otis and bond I just loved both of
those guys if you'd like to see more
seven deadly sins content on this
channel be sure to leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so feel free to follow us
there at anime uproar as always thank
you all so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]